Після 10-годинної подорожі киянка Ірина Гавриляка може нарешті розпакувати свою валізу -
у кімнаті для гостей у польському монастирі в Перемишлі, за 15 кілометрів від українського кордону.
Вона прибула зі своїми двома доньками, братом і сестрою.
Українка не хоче, аби її діти стали свідками війни.
Коли я отримала повідомлення зі школи, що в школі проведені навчання,
що підготовлені підвали, що там є запас води на кілька днів, їжа, іграшки для дітей, що там є ковдри,
що якщо щось таке застане дітей у школі, що вони можуть 5 днів перебувати у такому безпечному підвалі,
то, звісно, ти розумієш, що все це дуже-дуже серйозно.
Через страх перед вторгненням російських військ жінка попросила про притулок у цьому монастирі.
Спершу лише на тиждень, бо понад усе хотіла б, щоб незабаром знову змогла повернутися додому.
Але Ірина продумала план дій і на випадок найгіршого.
У Перемишлі є школа української меншини. Якщо розпочнеться війна, Ірина хоче віддати сюди своїх доньок.
З директором школи Петром Піпкою вона вже все узгодила.
Тут усі вчителі розмовляють двома мовами: польською та українською.
Тож спілкуватися з цими дітьми не було б проблемою.
Я також думаю, що для молодих українців, які приїдуть сюди, Польща, безумовно, стане другою батьківщиною.
У Перемишлі проживають тисячі українців. А по всій Польщі - понад мільйон.
Багато хто втік до сусідньої країни, коли почалася війна на Донбасі.
Досі їх тут приймали переважно як дешеву робочу силу.
Але нова хвиля українських біженців викликає неоднозначні відчуття у поляків,
не в останню чергу через історичні конфлікти.
Раніше вони нас вбивали, я їх не люблю.
Але якщо їм потрібна буде допомога, то ми повинні допомогти.
Усі бояться цієї війни, тому що ми не знаємо, які наслідки вона матиме.
Може бути наплив мігрантів до Польщі та в інші країни.
Ночівлю я б їм не запропонувала, але перекусити - так. Я живу одна, тому я би боялася.
Я не раз зверталася до українського стоматолога, бо ціни хороші, і ніколи не була розчарована.
Але сьогодні я не можу сказати, чи допоможу.
Попри такий скепсис польський прем'єр-міністр Матеуш Моравецький запевнив,
що Польща не відвернеться від українських біженців.
Ми повинні бути готові до найгіршого. Найгірше означає напад Росії на Україну,
повномасштабна війна, як кажуть військовослужбовці.
Це може призвести до масової втечі з України.
Ми також готові захищати східний фланг НАТО,
але з гуманітарної точки зору ми допоможемо Україні та українцям у разі нападу Росії пом’якшити наслідки цього нападу.
Уся інфраструктура буде підготовлена для цього у Східній Польщі,
але також з розгортанням в інших частинах країни.
Тим часом у Фундації польсько-українського співробітництва "U-Work" у Кракові застерігають,
що Польща не здатна буде прийняти усіх потенційних біженців з України.
У найгіршому, найтрагічнішому сценарії, якщо напад відбудеться з трьох сторін
і якщо бої будуть досить кровопролитними, ми очікуємо хвилю близько 3-5 мільйонів біженців, які приїдуть до Польщі.
Раніше польська влада заявляла, що готова прийняти до одного мільйона українських мігрантів.
Але якщо їх буде більше…
Я думаю, що ні Краків, ні Польща наразі не готові до такої великої хвилі міграції.
Тепер ми чуємо, що деякі місцеві губернатори намагаються поволі з’ясувати, де можна буде розмістити біженців.
Як, приміром, ось тут, на польському пункті пропуску "Медика".
Спортивний центр у цій невеликій польській громаді прямо на кордоні готовий прийняти українських біженців.
Поки що центр у Медиці пустує.
На прикордонному переході поки немає жодних ознак напливу українців.
Паніки немає. Не видно, щоб мешканці намагалися якось захиститися.
Але я все ще непокоюся: що буде, якщо почнеться хвиля біженців з України?
Це те, чого наші мешканці бояться найбільше.
Киянка Ірина Гавриляка сподівається, що війни і хвилі біженців не буде.
Власну поїздку до Польщі вона сприймає як свого роду страхування життя.
Ми купуємо медичну страховку або страховку на автомобілі,
сподіваючись, що вони нам ніколи не знадобляться.
Так і тут - ми приїхали погостювати, відпочити цей тиждень як страховка для наших дітей, що вони будуть у безпеці.
Але дуже сподіваємося, що це тільки страховка, вона ніколи не знадобиться.
Жінка хоче залишитися в Польщі доти, поки знову не зможе відчувати себе в повній безпеці на батьківщині.